temps d'attenté les connais prenez un
micro comprend rien vous plaît qu'est ce
qui se passe encore là dans le public on
a en direct oui quel est votre prénom
quel est votre prénom ou andreas andres
qu'est-ce qui se passe ce que je vois
vous agitez depuis tout à l'heure dans
le public parce que je veux bouger parce
qu alors quoi anthony ou monsieur à la
casse qui luttent pour fait serge pas
quoi là patrick bédié illuminé oui oui
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait un salut nazi
il a fait une quenelle ref vérifier les
images divines port pendant que jim et
moi avec qui a vu lundi qui a vu opposer
le merci merci merci
il avait une quenelle à ce que à ce qu à
ce moment là on accepte sur le plateau
je vais c'est comme ça et l'obsession
plus jamais honte mais le outrancier
comme un non mais là elle me faisait
alors face à ont fait pas ça ici c'est
inadmissible non mais je vous le dis
rija on vous laisse t on était aux
élucubrations que tout à l'heure
là franchement si c'est tous les jours
regarder sous le bateau je vous dis vous
pouvez quitter ma prenez vos affaires et
quitté le plateau merci monsieur bédié
mamers
merci merci merci merci merci merci à
vous les gars s'il vous plaît merci
aller vers celle observée les ministres
allez merci monsieur bédié au gallon
respectent les distances de sécurité
merci monsieur bélier voilà ça c'est
n'importe quoi
vraiment on veut pas sur les plateaux on
a écouté vos histoires on a été vraiment
en plus compréhensif on a essayé même de
d'essayer de défendre l'indéfendable
mais là monsieur minutie la possible je
planifie connaît